c'est c'est toujours la bataille des
chiffres en ce qui concerne ces ce
ping-pong entre le Kremlin et kif les
militaires Ukrainiens annoncent avoir
tué plus de 400 soldats russes dans ce
centre de déploiement temporaire alors
que vous l'avez dit la Russie de son
côté affirme avoir perdu au moins une
soixantaine d'hommes toujours est-il que
admettre ceci c'est déjà la preuve que
c'est probablement le plus gros revers
pour l'armée russe sur un territoire
temporairement
occupé celui en l'occurrence de Donetsk
dans le don-basse ce qui est plus rare
c'est la reconnaissance de l'armée
ukrainienne qui finalement avoue que
c'est bien de son côté que ça s'est
produit qui même va jusqu'à faire preuve
d'ironie de sarcasme sur Twitter le
ministre ministère de la Défense
ukrainienne qui s'est fendu d'un tweet
hier soir en disant de titillait pas nos
highmars il mordent sous-entendu
effectivement il confirme des facto que
ce sont bien des lance-roquettes
highmars qui auraient fait ces victimes
du côté russe dans le même temps hier il
y a eu une frappe à la frontière nord de
l'Ukraine sur le territoire russe cette
fois-ci qui n'a pas été confirmé par
l'Ukraine le directeur du renseignement
militaire bounaff hier a donné à
accorder une interview à NBC qui lui a
demandé mais est-ce que vous
reconnaissez ces frappes non absolument
pas et ce que vous en satisfaisez oui on
s'en satisfaits est-ce que vous pensez
que c'est frappe vont perdurer et
qu'elles vont aller encore plus loin et
il a répondu deeper and Deepers
sous-entendu oui nous allons frapper
même s'il ne l'a pas admis directement
encore plus loin sur le territoire russe